today until is a multi-billion dollar
business pulling in sixty two point
seven six billion u.s. dollars of
revenue in 2017 they employ over 100,000
people and over smaller companies like
McAfee and altaira they have everything
from a simple of G 4560 dual-core
processor for just under $60 all the way
to there was a young eighty one eighty
twenty eight core CPU for $11,000 but
where exactly did this company come from
and how exactly did it come to dominate
the CPU market but Before we jump into
that make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more origin stories just like this one
so starting off with Intel Corporation
was founded on July 18 1968 by two
semiconductor pioneers Gordon Moore and
Robert Noyce and it is often associated
with the vision of will Andrew Grove
Robert Noyce had actually co-founded
another semiconductor chip company named
Fairchild Semiconductor in 1957 today
Fairchild also just barely breaks two
billion dollar revenue mark and was a
private oh and semiconductor in 2016 for
a cool 2.4 billion dollars in cash but
endo would have been possible with just
Robert Noyce Arthur Rock who was
actually the chairman of Intel and the
major investor and the company actually
believed its that for Intel to succeed
as a company
Robert Noyce Gordon Moore and Andrew
Grove had to make the dream deep noise
was the man with the vision and source
of inspiration and more and growth were
the men with the brains to make it a
reality
well once these men got together they
went straight to work first what should
they name it the action named it annum
electronics but soon changed to just a
month later they ended up taking their
words integrated and electronics and
combined them to make Intel the men
found in town Mountain View California
and put in a whopping 2.5 million
dollars into it
in just two years Intel went public and
raised six point eight million dollars
at twenty three and a half dollars a
share in two actually started off making
ramp before jumping on into the CPU
space their first product was the 3101
Scott Key TTL bipolar which was super
compact yet impressive in speed in fact
it was twice as fast as the RAM that
existed at the time made by Fairchild
however until it didn't stop there in
that same year it don't came out with
our OEM or read-only memory and em OS Fe
T or metal-oxide-semiconductor
field-effect transistors eventually in
to learn from these products and
eventually came out with a dram or
dynamic random-access memory which
eliminated many of the issues with the
previous generations in 1970 it don't
continue to bring out remarkable
products like the first commercially
available microprocessor in 1971 and
ordered first microcomputers in 1972
however by 1983 Intel was losing steam
and their business heavily depended on
DRAM and in his competition from
Japanese semiconductor manufacturers did
not help the problem eventually gordon
moore the CEO at the time realized that
in talk should focus on building
microchips due to the high success of
IBM personal computers which were based
on it does microprocessors once Intel
changed our vision going forward they
experienced a crazy boom throughout the
80s which boosted Intel from being a
primary hardware supplier to becoming
the most profitable harder supplier to
the PC industry in tow was able to build
a great brand or loyalty and were able
to make Pentium a household name by the
end of 1990 this exponential growth
continued to the 90s with dozens of
commercial
and the boom of Windows until end to the
90s with twenty nine point four billion
dollars in revenue in 1999 however intoa
had some trouble sustaining their growth
into the new millennium until had been
placing some of those issues for a while
now and the new century just brought
more challenges with it in the u.s.
intellectual property rights related to
circuit layouts was actually protected
until 1984
after the semiconductor chip Protection
Act of 1984 in Todd tried to take
advantage of this new law and begin
suing other companies who try to develop
competitor chips to the 80386 CPU
however in most cases these legal
battles dragged on for some time and
Intel had to deal with cumbersome legal
bills on top of this antitrust
allegations had been raising issues for
in Towson's - early 1990s and this
actually led to one lawsuit against
Intel in 1991 going back to the early
2000s demand for high-end
microprocessors had stalled and good
competition began to rise mostly from
AMD at first
AMD only challenged info on the low and
mid-range processors but soon enough
there were a serious threat to Intel CPU
line-up AMD was able to pick up a lot of
market share and Intel a dominant
position was greatly reduced Craig
Barrett who was a CEO at this time was
aware of such issues and attempted to
diversify info beyond semiconductors but
alas most of these diamonds made however
after getting a new CEO named Paul
Otellini until was able to slowly regain
her position
in 2005 paul reorganized the company in
order to better serve each markets he
created the divisions enterprise digital
home digital health and mobility in 2006
in tok came out with their core
microarchitecture and this provided
significant performance of critic and
helped in to regain its glorious
position intone knew they had to focus
on the cpu market and so they announced
that they were going to sell as scale
assets Marvell Technology Group acquired
this for six hundred million dollars
that same year then in 2008 in tow
brought out the pattern architecture
based on the 45 nanometer process and
later that same year they introduced
McCollum which also had really great
feedback meanwhile until became greedy
again and tried to expand in 2008
spectra watt which was a solar start
company helped from Frank leprosy in
just three years
however their CPU sales are doing great
and with the reduced competition from
AMD until continued to innovate until
the 2700 K which came out in 2011 by
this point Intel had reclaimed their
dominance in the cpu market and there
wasn't much competition from AMD or
anyone else really Intel was simply D
go-to option for PC enthusiasts or even
simple laptop or desktop buyers duty in
toast
various marketing techniques for an oil
tea and of course superior performance
the next couple of years into a cruise
through cpu launch is simply adding a
little speed to processors year after
year while making some smart
acquisitions like Kathy and Infineon in
2010 altaira in 2015 mobile I in 2017
and many many more
while Intel received some backlash from
the community for stopping innovation it
Dell sales were still rocketing so they
didn't seem to worry much however in
2017 AMD's introduction of write-ins
showed many PC enthusiasts what value as
possible and this stole a lot of Intel's
market share in just a few months
eventually into a rush Derek's release
of coffee link which led to stock
shortage and more controversy about if
Intel would have released those chips if
AMD hadn't brought in some competition
today it is still widely converse about
what Intel is going to do next
and if Intel is going to finally bring
an octa-core processor to the mainstream
platform this year in tow still has
market dominance but they may not in the
imminent future if they continue to lose
market share as rapidly as they are
right now so what happens next make sure
to post down the comments below what you
guys expect for Intel in the future and
also comment down below what companies
or injen you want me to cover next also
make sure to hit that like button if you
guys found this video fun and
informative and don't forget to
subscribe but until next time